welcome everyone to this topic
on continuous integration delivery and
deployment
so this topic by simply learn is going
to explain you that what exactly
is all about the continuous integration
process continuous deployment
and continuous delivery so let's talk
about these concepts one by one
so continuous integration isn't kind of
a process which is which comes up in the
first part right
so first the continuous integrations
comes into the picture then the
continuous delivery and the deployment
comes into the part
so the main important component or the
main task which we primarily perform in
the continuous integration
is all about the build automations test
executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code
from the each and individual developers
machines to a shared location
which we often call it as an kind of a
version control system
so continuous integration is integrating
the source code into the shared
repositories
and then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
version control system
the automated build test cases all these
executions can really happen
now in the build process and the test
cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working
uh how the compilation is going on how
the test cases are getting executed
so all these things are getting
validated during the execution of these
things
now once the continuous integration is
successful we can
not assure give a hundred percent surety
that the code base is working fine
because it's just taking care of the
compilation and the test cases
there could be a possibility that some
kind of errors
may also come up into the production
environment because those test cases or
those scenarios are not being covered in
the test cases
so test cases are very important aspect
over here because
it's giving us the authority whether we
need to proceed further
or we need to halt there itself so after
the continuous integration the next
process which comes into the picture is
the automatic
release to the repository over here
right so it's just
a kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
to the particular component
so that kind of automation is available
but that is also
happening when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as an kind of
continuous deployment over here
so these are the overall process which
we are looking forward
so that we will be able to have an
end-to-end automations going on
over here with the help of ci cd
automations
now continuous indications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being
used by most of the development teams
nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code
uh whatever the changes or whatever the
modifications they are doing they can
uh particular uh you know like merge
their source code from their local
systems to the central repository
so that after that with the help of ci
tools we can actually have the
build automations and the test cases
automation there so this is the reason
why we
prefer the continuous integration
process because it depends on the basis
of our modifications that how the whole
build and test cases
automations can really happen here now
continuous integration is considered as
a very important process because of the
various reasons
let's talk about those reasons one by
one the very first one is that it
avoids the merge conflicts because if we
frequently uh sync back
our source code from our systems to the
shared repository and the same thing can
be done by other developers also
so eventually it definitely helps the
different developers to
collaborate their source code into a
single shared repository
and that can really help you to avoid
the merge conflict situations because
you are always going to work on the
latest source code so
the scope of merge conflicts is not
going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review
because we are just doing the uh
collaboration frequently so
uh we don't require any person to be
sitting there and you know have
uh to perform a kind of a heavy duty
code review because uh
that is something which we can easily
manage and we can work with that so code
review
uh is something which we can easily
decrease with the help of this
continuous integration
process uh it also speeds up the
development process
yes definitely because the developers
can easily collaborate with each other
so from collaboration perspective also
it's beneficial for us to do
and that can really help us to see that
how easily we can integrate our source
code
and that differs or that basically helps
us to go for the
overall mechanism and you know going for
an perfect automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented
during the ci process next it
also reduce the product backlog because
we are doing our changes frequently into
the repositories
so uh any kind of product backlog which
is there which is pending from long
that is also can be managed easily
because it's keep on you know reduce
there so we keep we keep on implementing
our changes we keep on implementing
merging us particular changes to the
share repository
so that reduces the amount of backlog
which is available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the
particular uh building testing
delivering improvements to the software
code
so the important part of continuous
delivery is that the code is always in
the deployable state
so we are saying that we are done with
the delivery we are ready with the
delivery
and whichever environment whichever
particular server you want
us to deploy we are ready to do that
so that is where we call it as in
continuous delivery so we have our
artifacts ready
and whenever is desired whenever we feel
that we want to do the deployments we
want to proceed further
we will be able to do that with the help
of this process
so it's in kind of an end-to-end process
you do the belts
you do the test cases executions once
the test case execution is done once the
testing is done
then you create an artifacts you create
a particular war files
jar files er files whatever the
artifacts we have we prepare that
artifacts
and then we deliver it to a specific
environment we say that yes let's go
with the delivery
let's make it into a particular state
where we will be able to deploy
to pretty much any environment which we
feel as such over here
so that's a real beauty about the
continuous delivery where we can
actually deliver it to whatever
environment we feel
we want to deliver now
continuous delivery is uh also something
which is a very
important concept for most of the
organizations so
uh each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one
for a variety of reasons because uh it's
something where we can invest
some of our particular efforts budget
money lot of things are there
but the kind of benefits which we get in
the return
that's what we are going to talk about
over here as such so let's go with that
so it provides the higher quality of
products yes the efforts are there yes
the investment is also there
but in the return the prime the very
important concept or very important
thing which we get
is the high quality of products here so
the kind of quality which we are getting
with this one
is quite high and that's the biggest
benefit which we get when we talk about
any kind of continuous integration
continuous delivery
or continuous deployment here so the
quality is always
top notch when we work of these
particular processes it also helps us to
go for a quicker
and less risky releases so that's
another benefit which we get this
process
customers are also satisfied because
they feel that yes we are going with
this
particular automated process within you
know few days we are getting the
deliveries
uh we don't have to wait for months for
getting our delivery so that's the
biggest benefit
which a customer usually gets when he
talks about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of fitness of the team also so
from the cost
and from the uh particular up efficiency
all those parameters are fully fulfilled
when we talk about the continence
delivery so this process delivers
a lot of benefits which can eventually
help us to go for an perfect high
quality product which we can develop
as such over here now the next thing is
the continuous deployment which is an
automatic deployment to the production
environment
so let's see that what exactly is in
continuous deployment all about here
so continuous deployment uh refers to
the final stage
in the pipeline so which means that the
we are not only preparing our artifacts
we are not only doing the
uh particular uh compilations or test
cases executions
we are actually going one step ahead and
this one step ahead is nothing but the
deployment to the production environment
so this is what we are typically doing
when we talk about the continuous
deployment over here that we are going
to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment
so that our changes whatever the changes
we are trying to do we are trying to
make
that should be deployed to the
production environment right
now so continuous deployment again is
can be deployed to uh
hire whatever the organizations want to
feel or want to deploy they can actually
go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment
so let's see about all these particular
deployments one by one so first of all
the faster development of the products
is there
so we are looking forward that when we
are going for the automations when we
are going for this deployment
so it we get a kind of a faster uh you
know development process which is there
so
the products are getting developed very
quickly very fast that's the biggest
benefit which you are getting when we
talk about this continuous deployment
here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix
problems whatever the automations we are
feeling we are trying to perform
that can definitely help us to go that
how we can automate and how we can
go for these uh particular releases over
here so these are releases are very
less risky because we are doing all the
things automated there is not much of a
scope which is there for the manual
errors
so usually manual errors is something
which is the biggest uh
problem or which is the biggest risk
when we go for any release but that is
something which is totally
removed with this automation here now it
also
helps in continuous improvement in the
quality so continuously improve
quality is also getting improved as such
here
now let's talk about that why exactly as
and we
talk about at the industry level in the
market level also
that the ci cd is one of the best
practices now what is the reason behind
that
why those are known as the best
development and devops practices
as such now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices
as they create an effective process the
kind of integration and delivering the
source code
these are the prime things which we need
to take care when we talk about the
development
uh teams over here so they want an
automated process
first of all and they also want to
streamline process which
can you know take up the things uh which
should not fail
it should be a fail-safe process
mechanism
through which they can release various
kind of changes to the production
environment
because ultimately they are looking
forward for the deployment of their
changes to the production environment
so how they are going to do that that is
where the ci cd or the continuous
integration and continuous
delivery helps on that part and that's
the reason why they can
help the teams the development teams to
go for an
effective process implementations
when we go for these implementations of
these two
practices small call changes can be
easily made in the software course so
you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment
in a simple straightforward and easy
mechanism the changes
can go from the developer machines to
the production environment that's the
biggest benefit
which we get due to which we feel that
yes these two processes
should be implemented into a devops
platform
right so ca and cd provides continuous
feedback from the customers
and also from their development teams
devops teams
so the increase of transparency is also
something which is
important which is implemented with
these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment
provided we do all these steps like
build compilations
testing development validation all these
things will be done in that duration of
time so the failures can
be easily detected faster and uh you can
easily find out that
what is the problem with the code base
what is the problem that changes and we
can even do the hot fixes
now hot fixes these kind of ad hoc
changes are also can be easily deployed
to a production environment
within just a couple of hours there so
that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the acd
and the prime important concept which we
have
got a proper understanding is that why
these two processes
are really important for our development
process and the only benefit which we
are getting
the prime benefit which we are getting
from these processes implementation
is that we get a effective build process
effective test cases automation or
process and
automated deployment process and these
processes when we combine
that is something which we can use to
deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the
end user so that's how the cacd
automations
really works into a devops environment
so that's it for this topic
thanks
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here